[Musique]
bonjour vu daniel berten bonjour bonjour
à toute la martinique président de la
chambre d'agriculture est pressenti pour
être président de l'odeadom c'est
l'office de développement économique de
l'outre-mer on y reviendra demain louis
daniel berten demain il y aura cette
visite de 24 heures de stéphane travert
c'est le ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
alors j'ai regardé le programme on
parlera diversification agroalimentaire
en parla de la filière pêche de
l'enseignement agricole de calamity de
la banane tous de tout sauf de la
filière viande qui alimente ce qui
alimente les débats depuis quelques
temps pourquoi cette mise à l'écart de
cette filière viande logiquement la
filière viande ne fait pas assez de la
diversification donc cette filière
aurait dû être traitée ou en tout cas
devait traiter dans cette partie là
alors c'est vrai que j'ai reçu une
invitation un peu lumineux vers midi
demain et où des organisations agricoles
sont également invités alors je constate
effectivement que ben aucune
organisation de la filière viande est
invité à cet incident quand tout va
c'est dommage parce que là où j'ai
proposé que la chambre de l'agriculture
accueille le ministre de l'agriculture
et puisse effectivement en temps de
l'ensemble des composants de du monde
agricole s'est passée cette filière
viande quelque chose à dire assez ceux
qui organisent inquiets ceux qui
organisent qu'il faut de poser la
question résultat une grande colère une
colère est le suivant par le même de
boycott de cette visite de stéphane
travert mais c'est normal je crois que
ce que dès lors qu'on est quand des gens
l'autre une visite ministérielle ses
succès c'est une action quelque chose de
très important et pour une profession
comme comme l'agriculture ou le dernier
mini ce qu'est venu pendant son exercice
en martinique c'était monsieur pendant
pradines 2 en 2007 c'était le mini de
l'époque monsieur banier est donc depuis
nous n'avons pas eu deux ministres la
ville tu revenant ici
bon il y avait plusieurs ratés parce que
monsieur le foll devenir bon il ya eu
les attentats en france il a dû au parti
depuis la guadeloupe mais nous n'avons
pas de ministre les gens sont en attente
la cité soleil france les gens mais
maintenant je suis en colère
vous êtes rentré hier soir de paris lui
daniel berten avait appris ce qui s'est
dit ces derniers temps notamment sur nos
antennes ce matin encore dans france
antilles avec l'autorité de la
concurrence qui demandent des règles
claires sur la gestion des fonds
européens et les fonds du possible via
l'odeadom via la mise l'interprofession
de de la viande que dit le président de
la chambre d'agriculture de tout ce
remue ménage alors il ya deux choses
il y à la gestion des fonds européens
bon j'ai interrogé les gens qui sont en
charge de ces dossiers là on me dit
qu'il ya pas de choses les choses sont
claires les les contrôles sont fait l
oncav interrogé agen théorie la daf j'ai
interrogé l'odeadom et on me dit que
bien ils n'ont pas trouvé de file et les
fonctions sont changés par contre moi je
dis je le répète depuis très longtemps
il y une problématique qui veut que une
op est obligé de recevoir d agriculture
d agriculture pour que cela puisse
bénéficier des fonds européens
or le constat que je fais c'est que
souvent des op mettre dehors des
agriculteurs une fois que l'inclusion
plus dans une op ils sont morts ou
économiquement parce qu'il est préfacé
par opter au pc organisation producteurs
des coopératives notamment ça veut dire
qu'ils sont obligés s'ils veulent
bénéficier des aides européennes
ils sont obligés à près de monter leur
propre et d'augmenter leur propre
organisation association ou autre et
donc demandé leur adhésion à l'ue
concernant l'élevage c'est la multi
joueurs qui gère les fonds donc il faut
qu'ils donnent leur adhésion à la mise
si en plus ils sont pas acceptés dans
les coopératives
ils sont pas incités à l'âme il ya un an
une difficulté et un problème 66
athlètes et à paris et à bruxelles
pourquoi et comment sommes-nous arrivés
à un stade où l'autorité de la
concurrence s'est abonnée à intervenir
il ya quand même des filtres que
représentent les services de l'état des
directions locales de services de l'état
qui sont présents martine yg on le
rappelle des plaintes ont été déposées
aujourd'hui tout le monde semble s'en
étonner pas dans la profession
ah non pas dans la profession moi je
crois que la chaîne l'agriculture avait
déjà d'un certain nombre de choses si
elles avaient été écoutés je pense que
beaucoup de choses qui se passent
maintenant ne se serait pas passé parce
que je pense qu'il faut qu'on connaît ou
encore un peu plus plus grandes dents
dans ce qui se passe dans dans les
structures il faut que les structures
soit un peu mieux gérer et il faut et
nous l'avons dit depuis très longtemps
déjà vous fait une proposition à une
époque pour qu'il y ait une sorte de
mutualisation au sein de la filière
viande ce qui a été en partie fait
n'avons pas être non plus suivi dans
toutes nos propositions mais je crois
qu'il faut effectivement qu'on connait
on regarde plus grands danseurs parce
que non seulement bon c'est une société
coopérative qui gère l'activité de leurs
adhérents mais également ils gèrent des
fonds européens
oui alors par de cartellisation du
marché de la viande c'est ce que
souligne le quotidien du jour ce sont
des mots très forts qui peuvent faire
mal et un homme le président de m'a dit
viens cristallise les regards etrait
remonte en ce moment il est en colère
quand alfred marie-jeanne le président
de la ccm du conseil exécutif lorsque ce
dernier avait dénoncé des tonnes de
viande jeter à la poubelle il est
remonté contre le journal inter
entreprises qui évoquait des plaintes
déposées à paris et vous c'est en
septembre ange milhas qui met en avant
sa volonté d'avoir entrepris d'avoir
structuré d'avoir organisé d'avoir
nettoyé d'orphée la viande de la viande
de la promotion de la viande locale
un vrai succès est ce que ce sont des
problèmes d'hommes où ce sont des
problèmes de fonctionnement des
structures
je pense qu'il s'agit d'épauler le
fonctionnement de ce que je crois que il
y à des actions qui ont été faites
notamment divialle mondiale
est issu d'une action qui a démarré la
chambre d'agriculture
c'est pas comme ça que nous nous avions
souhaité la réorganisation de la filière
mais elle a été faite comme ça par les
acteurs mais c'est bien ceci dit des
rien il y a le problème de gestion de
ces structures là comme elles sont
gérées avec quels objectifs on nous dit
qu'ils oublient que le facteur premier
c'est l'agriculture c'est le producteur
et c'est à lui qu'il est con con qu'on
doit avant d'écouter ça s'est servi
d'eux qu'on doit en des services alors
certes c'est à dire alors des cultures
sont très remontés ils ne comprennent
pas pourquoi ne sont pas présentés ils
sont pas présentés demain au ministre de
l'agriculture car ils ont des doléances
notamment pourquoi la justice ne met pas
plus son nez dans ses affaires d'autant
plus qu'il ya des plaintes de déposées
pourquoi la justice ne fait pas son
travail
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
dirai demain au ministre les problèmes
de justice si les gens ont déposé
plainte il faut quelques kills et
satisfaction il faut que les plaintes
soit huit bons et ça justement ça nous
permettrait effectivement le devoir d'y
voir plus clair parce que je crois qu'il
faut arrêter aussi de 2,2 fait de la
suspicion et c'est de l'invention de la
profession qui en pâtit parce que tout
le monde et donc il faut qu'on a il faut
qu'on a avec ça et qu'on puisse vous
retrouver un climat serein pour
développer l'agriculture martiniquaise
sauf cependant c'est pas au président de
la chambre de deux des ses rangs deux
choses la bcc bien sûr aux coopératives
qui sont concernés par pas ça mais
également au syndicalisme et je crois
que le syndicalisme fait son boulot à ce
niveau là alors on l'a dit vous êtes le
président annoncé de l'odeadom on attend
la publication de deux décrets
présidentiels concert de diam's et
l'office de développement économique de
l'outre-mer
il y à d'autres nominations notamment
dans dans ces communes orb sectoriel du
secteur un comité sectoriel il y en a
quatre et il ya la filière animale et on
y retrouve encore une fois en jeu milhas
qui cristallise beaucoup de regards à
tort ou à raison mais qui cristallise
beaucoup de regards et certaines voix
demandent sa mise à l'écart
encore une fois est ce quelqu'un que par
n'y a pas
une chasse à l'homme dans ce dossier
mais je ne sais pas s'il ya une chasse à
l'homme mais je sais que effectivement
cette candidature
et puis d'autres aussi un pose problème
parce que ça m'a été dit ceci dit la
façon dont sont nommés les représentants
dans les comités sectoriels
c'est même sa sono diadème également
c'est qu'il ya une consultation du
préfet c'est le préfet qui qui propose
les noms et ensuite concernant le comité
secteur sensations avec le directeur de
la culture et des forêts bien sûr que je
le confesse le préfet qui avec ses
services mais c'est le préfet qui quand
même s'il est donc il y doit faire ça
aussi en concertation avec la profession
agricole
absolument donc et concernant les
comités actuelle c'est le directeur de
le diadème qui n'ont donc il prend un
arrêté de qu'il nomme l'élément est donc
le plus le directeur de l'odeadom que
j'ai interrogé sur sa jeu on s'est
rencontrés mercredi après la proposition
de ma candidature pour la présidence je
lui ai posé cette question là il m'a dit
ben si on me fait deux propositions mais
il ya d'autres gens qui seront nommés
nous sommes très pris par le temps tout
cela ça sent le soufre à quelques heures
de la venue et stéphane travert
absolument quoique la circulaire la
situation agricole et dans un dans un
état dramatique je le dis comme ça on a
subi deux phénomènes climatiques très
important en l'espace d'une année nous
avons nous sommes confrontés à un
problème de fonctionnement des aides
européennes qu'ils ne ne se débloque pas
et est donc la vie culturelle est très
mal et donc le musée avec tout vient de
ces périodes là bien absolument il
aurait il va entendre tout ça merci
beaucoup je lui daniel berthiaume on
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la chambre d'agriculture merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nous dans son caddie
bonne journée merci
[Musique]